bonsoir à tous dans l'actualité ce soir
après les régionales l'elysée vient
d'annoncer un remaniement gouvernemental
très limité c'était il ya une demi heure
le chiraquien françois baroin fait son
entrée ainsi que georges tron proche de
dominique de villepin
xavier darcos est écarté le détail à
suivre nicolas sarkozy sarkozy a voulu
intégrer les composantes de sa majorité
cet ajustement fait suite aux désaveux
enregistrée hier par l'ump le parti
socialiste et ses alliés obtiennent 54%
des voix et vingt-et-une régions sur 22
en métropole
martine aubry est confortée le front
national lui est remise en selle nous
irons dans le vaucluse où on a voté à 38
ou 40 % pour le fn dans le reste de
l'actualité après le revers politique le
test social cinq syndicats appellent à
la grève demain pour l'emploi et les
salaires il faut s'attendre à des
perturbations dans les transports et à
l'école les prévisions dans un instant
aux etats unis la victoire politique de
barack obama le président américain a
fait passer in extremis sa réforme de la
santé
mais s'il a multiplié les concessions
nous serons en direct à washington une
autre voix contre le diabète gras la
chirurgie est désormais pratiquée pour
court circuiter l'estomac deux à trois
millions de personnes sont concernées en
france
et puis comment sauver le rhinocéros en
afrique la protection de l'espèce est
actuellement discuté à doha car le
braconnage continue malgré les démentis
médicaux sa corne reste prisé pour ses
pseudos vertus revitalisantes c'est le
dossier de cette édition
bienvenue dans ce journal les choses
n'ont donc pas traîner 24 heures
seulement après le deuxième tour des
régionales c'est un nouveau gouvernement
qui a été présenté il ya quelques
instants il s'agit davantage en fait
d'un ajustement alix bouilhaguet entrée
de morel dernière étape d'une journée de
tractations 18 heures françois fillon
revient à l'elysée dans son dossier
rouge lé nom de son nouveau gouvernement
une heure trente plus tard le communiqué
tombe le premier à en faire les frais et
c'est xavier darcos le ministre des
affaires sociales ne mènera donc pas la
réforme des retraites il devrait être
appelé à d'autres fonctions
un bouc-émissaire expliquer cet après
midi son entourage
xavier darcos est remplacé à son poste
par eric woerth qui quitte bercy
à ce jeu de chaises musicales c'est le
chiraquien françois baroin qui hérite du
portefeuille du budget il a été reçu
longuement à matignon en fin de journée
georges tron un proche de dominique de
villepin fait lui aussi son entrée au
gouvernement il devient secrétaire
d'état à la fonction publique
le départ du haut commissaire aux
solidarités actives martin hirsch était
programmé il est remplacé par le
centriste marc philippe daubresse qui
devient ministre de la jeunesse et des
solidarités actives
trois entrants et deux sortants
officiellement on n'est pas loin de là
justement techniques évoquées hier à
l'elysée dans la réalité il s'agit
surtout d'un signal fort on voyait la
majorité nicolas sarkozy s'exprimera
mercredi à l'issue du conseil des
ministres
on va s'arrêter un instant sur l'un des
trois nouveaux visages de cette équipe
françois baroin
si une particulier c'est un proche de
jacques chirac qui a souvent eu des mots
très durs y compris ces derniers temps
pour le pouvoir
valérie astruc il est quasiment le fils
adoptif de jacques chirac
et c'est sous la halle de l'ancien
président qu'il a débuté sa carrière en
93 plus jeune député à 27 cents en 95
porte parole de la campagne de jacques
chirac
ce dernier n'a jamais tari d'éloges
envers son poulain un homme politique un
peu atypique qui a je crois concentrer
toutes les qualités que l'on peut
espérer d'un homme politique sans en
avoir les travers plusieurs fois
ministre sous l'ère chirac
il remplacera nicolas sarkozy place
beauvau francs celui ci se lancera dans
la campagne présidentielle
mais depuis 2007 françois baroin est
resté simple député maire de troyes il
critiquera régulièrement l'action du
gouvernement comme par exemple la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle nous
allons sinon avoir les menottes aux
poignets nous les élus locaux puisque
nous avons dépendre dans nos budgets
plus de 50 portion des dotations d'état
après le premier tour des régionales il
avait critiqué l'ouverture qui crée
selon lui des courants d'air à droite en
entrant gouvernement françois baroin
incarne à présent l'ouverture dans les
chiraquiens
le grand perdant de ce petit remaniement
on l'a entendu c'est xavier darcos
c'est lui en tant que ministre du
travail qui devait mener la réforme des
retraites dans les prochains mois il
paye sa lourde défaite hier soir thierry
curtet xavier darcos agacé hier soir à
l'annoncé des résultats
si je prends les 30% dans une
triangulaire mais permettez moi de vous
dire c'est pas moi de le dire mais c'est
quand même un très joli score
28% des voix pour l'ump mais le double
56 % pour son adversaire socialiste
la défaite est sévère il savait
l'aquitaine terre de mission il avait
déjà perdu en 2004 mais il n'avait pas
fini à retourner au combat parce que
nicolas sarkozy le lui avait demandé
campagne pour aller au casse pipe pour
gagner
l'agrégé de lettres classiques qui fut
ministre de l'éducation avant d'être
ministre du travail avait su c'est dû à
nicolas sarkozy jusqu'à devenir membre
du cercle le plus rapproché autour du
président s'étaient rudy à l'image
plutôt provincial fut même un temps
premier ministrable ce soir il quitte le
gouvernement
tout en déclarant garder sa confiance à
nicolas sarkozy bonsoir michaël darmon
vous avez suivi toute cette journée vous
êtes en direct à l'elysée quelle
signification faut-il donner à ce mini
remaniement
écoutez ce soir clairement un nicolas
sarkozy parle à sa famille politique 1
avec le chiraquien françois baroin
le centriste marc philippe daubresse et
le villepiniste georges tron il s'agit
là bien sûr de contrer l'offensive
politique lancée au sein même de sa
majorité depuis le premier tour et la
défaite donc aux élections régionales je
rappelle que dominique de villepin doit
lancer son propre mouvement politique je
dis donc il s'agit bien là de reprendre
la main et d'essayer de faire en sorte
que notamment la réunion
donc demain des élus ump ne sert pas
trop de défouloir et surtout d'associer
l'ensemble sa majorité ou aux réformes
difficiles qui s'annoncent notamment
celle des retraites
michael un mot sur le cas de françois
baroin compte tenu de sa personnalité et
de son positionnement cette entrée est
elle une surprise oui c'est
effectivement assez étonnant on l'a vu
il a il a multiplié les critiques depuis
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy est encore
plus depuis la semaine dernière il était
opposé au remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux il était opposé
donc à l'ouverture
opposé au rythme des réformes
il s'avère quand même que derrière
toutes ces postures il avait depuis
plusieurs jours des conversations avec
nicolas sarkozy l'on trouvait
apparemment un terrain d'entente
il le reconnaît nicolas sarkozy aurait
donc entendu une partie ces critiques le
chef de l'état disait ces jours derniers
il est vrai que je fais beaucoup de
choses mais les français ne met pas le
doigt sur une réforme emblématique donc
ce sera donc celle des retraites
et là apparemment donc ils ont trouvé un
terrain d'entente avec un françois
baroin qui cherche aussi à se construire
un peu plus politiquement notamment par
rapport à jean françois copé et bruno le
maire un dernier mot au delà de ce
changement limité inde équipe
faut-il attendre un changement de fond
dans la politique suivie écoutez ce mini
remaniement s'est fait également sous
lens et d'un débat assez fort 1 entre
françois fillon et l'elysée françois
fillon voulait un remaniement beaucoup
plus large mais finalement l'elysée a
tranché donc pour ce type de remaniement
cela veut dire également que nicolas
sarkozy se réserve le droit donc de
faire un remaniement beaucoup plus large
sur le fond sur le cap des réformes
nicolas sarkozy cherche à garder le
volontarisme qui l'a fait gagner en 2007
mais il va intégrer quand même
maintenant un changement un changement
de rythme et se concentrer sur des
réformes l'essentiel ce sera je vous
l'avais dit donc celle des retraites au
cours de laquelle il va vouloir faire
donc une réforme marquantes et on voit
bien donc avec cet épisode que les
élections si elles sont régionales et
bien les conséquences elles sont
gouvernementale michaël darmon à
l'elysée merci michael on revient
maintenant sur ce qui est à l'origine de
ces changements dans l'équipe
gouvernementale on l'évoquait la défaite
sans appel de la majorité hier voici les
résultats définitifs 54,06 pour le parti
socialiste et ses alliés 35,37 pour
l'ump 9,17 pour le front national le fn
rappelons le n'était en lice que dans
une région sur deux son score réel est
en fait proche de 18% donc il ya donc
près de dix neuf points d'écart entre la
gauche et la droite parlementaire
c'est une victoire inédite pour le parti
socialiste depuis 1981 et du coup
regarder la carte des régions est
presque entièrement rose
seule l'alsace la réunion et la guyane
sont à droite
retour sur ces dernières heures qui ont
requinqué la gauche qu'elle vit un bear
arnaud bus avec notre bureau à poitiers
19 points d'écart avec l'ump le parti
socialiste retrouve le score de ses plus
belles années
hier soir les militants sont en fait les
résultats sont tombés
les doutes et d'allemand le parti pour
gagner en 2012
tabbou suis optimiste mais là cette
campagne a vraiment donné à du show
fatigués mais avec la tête des bons
jours martine aubry accepte de prendre
la pose pour ses admirateurs sur le
résultat en revanche il n'y a pas photo
selon elle le message des électeurs
s'adresse à nicolas sarkozy je lui
demande de changer de politique est
d'abord très simplement il a des mesures
à prendre tout de suite que la taxe
carbone ne pèse pas uniquement sur les
ménages qu'on n'augmente pas le gaz de
9% au 1er avril
hier soir une demi heure après les
résultats martine aubry s'offre un bain
de foule militants mais à poitiers
ségolène royal lui a grillé la politesse
largement réélu elle est la première
leader socialiste a parlé et la
présidente de poitou charentes s'exprime
elle aussi en responsable national
président de la république et le
gouvernement doivent comprendre que leur
politique
et puis la france et que les français
n'en veulent plus au ps la victoire des
régionales à peine consommée la
présidentielle de 2012 s'impose dans les
esprits
on a trop donné dans ces victoires qui
ont été transformés en grande défaite
ce coup ci ça doit être le début de
quelque chose et pas le début des
divisions
le cru 2010 confirme l'importance des
grands barons socialistes comme michel
vauzelle en paca jean paul huchon en
ile-de-france jean-jack queyranne en
rhône alpes ou encore martin malvy le
mieux élu en midi pyrénées demain photo
de famille prévue au siège du parti
avait tout sans ségolène royal c'est le
premier mystère de l'après élection et
s'il s'agit bien des élections
régionales martine aubry sort évidemment
conforté de cette victoire c'est aussi
l'histoire d'une résurrection et les
nuques le bonheur de martine aubry y est
soir après son triomphe aux régionales
loin des larmes de ce 6 juin 2002 l'ex
numéro deux du gouvernement jospin vient
d'être battu aux législatives à
travailler avec tous les élus de gauche
ici pour continuer à améliorer leur
situation
commence alors une longue période
d'isolement pendant huit ans martine
aubry se replie sur sa mairie de lille
elle se passionne pour sa ville la
transforme radicalement les municipales
de 2008 sont un triomphe réélu avec 66%
des voix
elle songe alors à son retour sur la
scène nationale sollicité par ses amis
mais aussi par laurent fabius et les
proches de dominique strauss kahn elle
se lance dans la succession à françois
hollande élections rocambolesque où ils
l'emportent d'une petite centaine de
voix face à ségolène royal
quelques mois plus tard les européennes
sont un échec
le ps ne pèse alors plus que ses ennemis
% martine aubry se remet au travail
impose sa méthode fermeté jeu collectif
retour aux valeurs
elle s'engage pleinement dans la
campagne des régionales la victoire
d'hier la place définitivement en chef
de l'opposition
rappelons que la gauche détenait déjà 20
régions métropolitaines
elle a aussi emporté en corse après 26
ans de pouvoir de la droite mais cette
victoire est relativisé par le succès
des nationalistes 35% des voix haute au
sol il y avait deux listes pour la
présidence de région tout se jouera
vendredi
et puis un mot d'europe écologie comme
prévu daniel cohn bendit a lancé son
appel du 22 mars pour dit-il
métamorphoser les verts il souhaite
inventé une coopérative politique ce
sont ces termes en vue de 2012
ils sont taillés pour faire un
championnat amateur alors que l'écologie
politique peut atteindre la ligue des
champions dit il et tout le monde mais
pas sur la même longueur d'onde
commentaires de cécile duflot ce soit il
ya des choses intéressantes mais
l'organisation est une chose secondes il
faut d'abord penser au projet voilà pour
la gauche
on en vient à la droite c'est l'un de
ses plus bas score sous la vème
république
hier soir vous l'avez entendu les ténors
ont reconnu la défaite
illustration de ce désaveu dans les
hauts-de-seine le département de nicolas
sarkozy la gauche est devenue
majoritaire entre jeunes aux maris crocs
habituellement c'est une terre
inhospitalière pour les roses du ps les
hauts-de-seine bastion de nicolas
sarkozy il si la gauche en tête ce n'est
pas un retour mais tout simplement une
première depuis la création du
département il ya plus de 40 ans j'avais
eu à parier j'aurais pensé que les
autres fai nous révolter plus à droite
qu'à gauche c'est sûr c'est un autre
sanction que pas se cacher et j'espère
que ça va encourager le gouvernement à
fléchir heures
opposition mais vous lisiez par rapport
à 2007 vous aviez voté sarkozy s et es
vous le désavouer maintenant mais hier
soir au conseil général
la gauche unie savourer sa victoire
mais avait bien du mal à la faire
admettre aux militants du npa qui ferez
nourris et coûtent 100 de certains
proches du président sarkozy
moi pécresse elle fait 60% dans ma
commune
franchement d'un cube c'est aujourd'hui
bien des villes du département
minoritaires qui n'auraient jamais plus
je trouve ça honteux
premier visé patrick devedjian mais
aussi rama yade et andré santini
tous trois sont maires de villes où la
gauche est arrivée en tête pour
reconquérir les hauts-de-seine nicolas
sarkozy pourra en revanche s'appuyer sur
la ville de neuilly dont il fut le maire
et où l'ump affiche est aujourd'hui
fièrement un score de 83 % la droite on
l'a dit sauve trois région philippe
richert pour l'ump et l'emportent assez
largement en alsace avec 46% des voix
contre 39 5 à la liste de la gauche
à la réunion on l'indiqué désir le
député maire ump du tampon didier robert
a battu paul vergès 85 ans à noter aussi
que la guyane est passé à droite à la
faveur du ralliement il ya quelques mois
de du maire divers gauche de cayenne
rodolphe alexandre qui l'emportent avec
56 % face à christiane taubira depuis
hier soir cette déroute de l'ump a
ouvert la porte aux critiques de
nombreuses voix se sont élevées en
interne pour demander des changements
romain mais si jean francois monier
frédéric lefebvre face à la frustration
des militants bloqué à l'extérieur du
siège de l'ump
le signe d'une atmosphère électrique 28
hier l'heure n'est plus à la langue de
bois comme au soir du premier tour mais
à la critique et aux rancoeurs sur les
plateaux télé jean françois copé dégaine
le premier
les français nous ont clairement adressé
à certain nombre de messages est parmi
ces messages il en est un que nous
devons retenir cm sur cellex c qui faut
revenir à nos fondamentaux c'est à ce
qui a permis l'élection de nicolas
sarkozy comme président de la république
en finir avec l'ouverture à gauche où la
taxe carbone des positions défendues par
jean françois copé est soutenu par jean
pierre raffarin l'ancien premier
ministre appelle ce matin nicolas
sarkozy à repenser ses réformes
il faut des changements concrets dans ce
qui te concerne la vie quotidienne
les françaises et des français ils sont
très inquiet ils ont peur que la crise
soit longue et sévère
il faut leur redonner confiance et pour
ça il faut montrer qu'on sait les
écouter on départ tension également sur
la stratégie du parti unique
les centristes ralliés à l'ump veulent
faire entendre leur voix les résultats
d'une élection bien l'électorat
centriste que nous le nouveau centre
nous avons vocation à rassembler avec
hervé morin cet électorat centriste et
nous le ferons dans les échéances
futures notamment l'élection
présidentielle au premier tour
lui aussi pense à 2012 dominique de
villepin devrait annoncer jeudi la
création d'un nouveau mouvement
politique au sein de l'ump et encourage
dans le même temps son principal
lieutenant georges tron à entrer au
gouvernement
deux fers au feu pour mieux préparer
l'avenir
voilà georges tron qu'on entendra donc
tout à l'heure ce cet ajustement
gouvernemental a donc été pensé
notamment pour répondre à cette fronde
de la droite et à en représenter toutes
les familles on en vient maintenant au
front national
images ici de marine le pen qui a
progressé à la faveur de ce deuxième
tour dans le nord-pas-de-calais 22,2
pour cent des voix ymagis aussi de son
père jean marie le pen en hausse
également 22,87 à noter que c'est à
quelques dixièmes près le score que nous
affichons hier dès 20h avec la tns
sofres alors quels sont les ressorts de
cette remise en selle du front national
pour le savoir nous sommes allés à
cavaillon dans le vaucluse
là bas on a voté à 38 % pour le fn
stéphane despinoy christophe laroque
ici de nombreux électeurs ayant voté
nicolas sarkozy en 2007 sont retournés
vers jean marie le pen à l'occasion des
régionales avec 38 % pour le fn
cavaillon crie son ras-le-bol
je suis un mot suis ravi
du passage du taux de du front national
vous estimez que les conditions de la
sécurité on se sont dégradées depuis
l'élection de monsieur m'a énormément je
suis comme beaucoup de cavaillonnais qui
ont peur de sortir même pour aller au
cinéma battu tous les jours il ya des
liens qui a agressé
vous avez dans un magasin ont fait la
caisse on vous braque les gens comme
vous et moi
à cavaillon les vols à l'arraché à main
armée ont fortement progressé en janvier
février mais ce n'est pas seulement ce
climat d'insécurité qui explique le
succès du fn montre le premier tour j'ai
fait un monstre de protestation et au
deuxième je suis rentré dans les rangs
nous qu'est ce qu'on peut espérer pour
faire entendre notre voix moi
personnellement c'est pas moi qui vais
allez définir dans la rue - j'ai que ce
moyen pour faire à voir que je suis pas
content et c'est un dicton à cause du
racisme ou la cause de des étrangers je
pense que les gens sur y énormément déçu
il a donné beaucoup aux riches mais ne
peut rien donner pour les pauvres
ici plus qu'ailleurs sans doute les
habitants de cavaillon ont voulu
protester contre les promesses jugées
non tenues voilà ce que l'on pouvait
dire ce soir sur ces régionales et leurs
conséquences nous y reviendrons donc en
fin de journal avec la première réaction
d'un nouveau membre du gouvernement le
villepiniste entre guillemets georges
tron dans le reste de l'actualité
après l'épreuve politique le test social
cinq syndicats appellent à la grève
demain pour l'emploi et les salaires
dans toute la france le public et le
privé
c'est d'abord à l'école et dans les
transports qu'il pourrait y avoir des
perturbations bonsoir sophie brune
vous êtes à la gare du nord à paris à
quoi faut-il s'attendre
écoutez pour les transports on peut
s'attendre à un trafic assez perturbé
mais pas à une journée noire la grève
vient de commencer à la sncf est pour
demain la direction prévoit deux tgv sur
trois en circulation un train corail sur
deux en région ça devrait être un ter
sur deux et puis à paris la ratp annonce
2 métros sur 3 en circulation les
attentions ce sont des moyennes le
trafic sera variable en fonction des
lignes
et il est donc préférable que les
voyageurs se renseignent sur les
horaires des trains effectivement en
circulation vous l'avez dit cette grève
ne concerne pas que les 30
or les syndicats appellent en effet à
une journée d'action
interprofessionnelle pour la défense de
l'emploi et des retraites
côté fonctions publiques le mouvement
devrait être bien suivi notamment dans
l'éducation nationale où de nombreux
établissements scolaires pourrait rester
fermé demain les agents des impôts sont
également appris à faire grève ainsi que
les fonctionnaires de justice
enfin les professionnels de la petite
enfance pour est également débrayé
demain entraînant la fermeture de
plusieurs crèches sur l'ensemble du
territoire
sophie brune à paris merci sophy pour
toutes ces indications à l'étranger il
lui fallait 216 voix il en a obtenu 219
barack obama a donc réussi à faire
passer sa fameuse loi sur l'assurance
maladie même si elle est largement
édulcoré dans un instant on verra en
direct il faut parler de victoire
d'abord images et explications avec
stéphane breitner sur toutes les chaînes
on ne parle que de cela de ce vote
historique de la nuit dernière
debout les démocrates exulte lorsque les
216 voix de majorité sont atteints puis
la présidente de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi clos radieuse
cette session extraordinaire
au même moment entouré de ses
conseillers barack obama savoure cette
victoire à l'arraché alors vers minuit
lorsqu'il s'avance devant la presse le
président a le triomphe modeste
le vote de ce soir n'est pas la victoire
d'un parti c'est leur victoire la
victoire du peuple américain
nous avons prouvé que ce gouvernement
travaille encore et toujours pour les
américains
jusqu'au dernier moment barack obama
aura tenté de convaincre pour que
dorénavant 30 2 millions d'américains
est une couverture médicale
ce sera principalement la classe moyenne
qui en bénéficiera pas assez pauvre pour
avoir les aides de l'état
pas assez riche pour se payer une
assurance avec cette loi les compagnies
ont obligation d'assurer chaque
américain
les hausses des primes seront limitées
et chaque entreprise sera obligé de
couvrir ses salariés ce soir les
républicains sont bien décidés à
multiplier les recours pour tenter
d'annuler cette loi avec des chances
quasi nulles de réussir bonsoir maryse
burgot vous êtes à washington peut-on
dire que la présidence de barack obama
est relancé oui parce que cette réforme
représente vraiment une révolution
et si barack obama voilà ça cela
s'appelle une rupture de faisceau et
nous espérons retrouver maryse burgot
dans quelques secondes ou tout à l'heure
à la fin de ce journal il est 20h20
resté avec nous à suivre le défi des
femmes à l'ordre talibans au pakistan
elles ont créé la première semaine de la
mode et elle défile publiquement sur les
podiums reportage sur place
le monde au chevet des rhinocéros le
sommet de doha veut pousser les états à
sanctionner davantage le braconnage
c'est le dossier de cette édition et
puis une page santé quoi de neuf contre
le diabète est bien l'intervention
chirurgicale
l'opération assez légère vous le verrez
pourrait changer la vie de deux à trois
millions de personnes
d'abord donc l'autre visage du pakistan
lorsqu'on évoque ce pays de 180 millions
d'habitants c'est généralement pour
parler des attentats ou de la poussée
des talibans et bien des hommes et
surtout des femmes ont décidé de braver
l'ain
hardy et de le braver au grand jour les
stylistes et des mannequins ont organisé
la première semaine de la mode envoyés
spéciaux arnauld miguet julien fouchet
paris milan new york
pas du tout nous sommes à lahore au
pakistan pour cette semaine de la mode
des mannequins 32 couturier 700 invités
ce défilé est une grande première
au pakistan même si on n'a pas de
commande ce n'est pas grave nous voulons
juste montrer au monde entier ce qu'on
est capable de faire
il n'y a donc pas que des femmes voilées
ou des barbus au pays des purs un autre
pâtissent temps existé a envie de donner
une autre image de lui même s'il vous
plaît montrer au monde ce côté ci du
pakistan mais tout n'est pas facile pour
autant
dans ce pays qui subit des attentats
quasi quotidiens et la pression des
islamistes
il faut se battre à l'image de marine 28
ans mannequin star dans son pays
elle vit dans cette maison avec sa mère
et sa soeur pense que cette profession
n'est pas respectable pour une femme à
cause de ce qui se passe en ce moment
et parce que nous sommes dans une
société dominée par les hommes
aujourd'hui très courtisé par la presse
et les couturiers les hommes de sa
famille l'ont pourtant répudier ya dix
ans parce qu'elle voulait faire ce
métier pas unique
les gens de notre famille sont très
conservateurs ne permettent même pas aux
femmes de sortir seuls et bien sûr ne
veulent pas que les femmes travaillaient
comme erin a décidé de devenir
aucun il était furieux retour à la mode
pour ce défilé très haute tension
ici ce soir la sécurité maximale on a
une vingtaine de tireurs d'élite postés
ici chacun à 81 10 cartouches sur lui
marine et ses amies mannequins se place
désormais à rêver que la horde de vienne
un jour une capitale de la mode
l'environnement maintenant on en parle
depuis des années mais rien ne change
vraiment comment sauver le rhinocéros en
afrique la protection de l'espèce est
actuellement discuté ici à doha par tous
les pays du monde
car le braconnage continue malgré les
démentis médicaux sa corne la corne du
rhinocéros reste prisé pour ses pseudos
vertu au kenya c'est le dossier de cette
édition il est signé de nos envoyés
spéciaux dominique derda et frédéric
ranque
c'est une véritable armée que comme john
pas mairie une armée au service de la
protection des animaux 140 hommes
équipés pour certains de fusils d'assaut
8 et jour il veille sur les
pensionnaires de la réserve de lewa et
tout particulièrement sur les 110
rhinocéros que compte ce sanctuaire de
25 mille hectares au pied du mont kenya
richard molères et le conservateur en
chef de l'est voient un métier pour
lequel mieux vaut avoir le coeur bien
accroché hier encore on suivait un
groupe de braconniers quand tout à coup
ils ont tiré sur l'avion
au marché noir le prix des défenses
d'éléphants et de corne du rhinocéros a
flambé ces derniers temps celui ci a été
abattu au printemps dernier à quelques
kilomètres de les voir surpris par les
gardes les services kényans de
protection de la nature de des
braconniers sont parvenus à s'enfuir
avec leur trophée les kenyans cause des
braconniers que là où il ya des
rhinocéros souvent il ya des gardes mais
ils sont prêts à tout et n'hésite jamais
à tirer un tandem pôle d'attraction
il y avait environ 20000 rhinocéros
noirs au kenya en 1970 ils sont environ
600 aujourd'hui et c'est grâce à des
réserves comme les oies s'ils n'ont pas
disparu dans la petite ville d'ys yolo
on raconte que souvent des hommes venus
de somalie offre des poignées de dollars
à quiconque leur rapportera une corne de
rhinocéros
la dernière saisie importante a eu lieu
à l'aéroport de nairobi la capitale
c'était en juillet 2009 dans ses caisses
il y en avait pour des centaines de
milliers d'euros elle était destinée à
vientiane au laos
une sacrée perte pour l'importateur le
commerce de la corne de rhinocéros est
officiellement interdite dans le monde
entier mais en asie la demande est en
constante augmentation
nombreux là-bas sont ceux qui croient
dur comme fer qu'un peu de pondre leur
rendre à leur virilité perdu et que la
kératine que l'on trouve dans la corne
les guérir à du cancer et de bien
d'autres maladies encore on ne gagnera
pas cette bière en se battant ici sur le
terrain on la gagnera si quelqu'un un
jour ça revient à faire baisser le prix
de la corne de rhinocéros pour cela il
faudrait qu enfin les gens comprennent
qu'elles ne soigne pas et ne guérit rien
ni personne entre le salaire de ses
gardes sans cesse en patrouille les
kilomètres de clôtures électriques qu'il
faut entretenir les heures passées à
survoler cette immense territoire
les oies dépense chaque année plus de
500 mille euros pour assurer la survie
de cette espèce menacée pour protéger
les rhinocéros il faut des moyens
considérables des moyens dont ne
disposent que les grandes réserves
privées comme celle-ci ailleurs ces
animaux sont des cibles faciles pour des
braconniers mieux armés et plus
déterminé que jamais en bref lé volcan
gronde à nouveau en islande l'éruption a
commencé sous ce glacier à 150 km de la
capitale reykjavik
des routes ont été fermées 600 habitants
ont été évacués
le feu et la glace celle islande le
volcan se réveille après cent
quatre-vingt dix années de sommeil
retour maintenant à washington nous
avons retrouvé maryse burgot la liaison
est rétabli bonsoir maryse peut-on
parler donc de rebond politique pour
barack obama de relance après le vote de
cette loi sur la santé
oui parce que cette réforme représente
vraiment une révolution
et même si barack obama échoue dans
d'autres domaines
il restera dans l'histoire celui qui a
arraché cette révolution jusqu'à présent
aux états unis l'accès aux soins et est
rarement un droit c'était surtout un
privilège cette époque est désormais
révolue alors oui barack obama a
beaucoup marchande et il a négocié il a
revu son programme à la baisse mais la
loi est bel et bien là alors barack
obama va maintenant devoir promulguer
cette loi
barack obama barack obama qui a bien sûr
essuyé beaucoup de revers ces derniers
temps sa méthode de compromis à tout
prix a même semé des doutes sur sa
véritable capacité à réformer mais
aujourd'hui cette victoire relance
véritablement son mandat merris burgaud
maryse burgot à washington merci maryse
la santé avec une autre voie un espoir
sans aucun doute contre le diabète gras
la chirurgie est désormais pratiquée
vous allez le découvrir le principe est
ingénieux il s'agit en quelque sorte de
court circuiter l'estomac deux à trois
millions de personnes sont concernées en
france
explication jean daniel flaysakier
lorraine christof loy fait le grand jour
pour brigitte joaillier elle a décidé de
se faire opérer une intervention qu'on
pratique pour traiter les obésités
important dans mais chez elle ce que
l'on vise c'est d'abord améliorer le
diabète dont elle souffre à 3 mois à 6
mois on prenait beaucoup de médicaments
quoi c'est combien de médicaments
oui et vous n'arrivez pas à trouver le
juste équilibre de votre direct avec ça
si l équilibre quand même mais si par
exemple j'oubliais un cachet ou si je
fais pas attention le diabète montrent
des centaines de patients diabétiques
ont déjà été opéré au chu lille trois
minuscules incision et le chirurgien va
découper une petite poche à partir de
l'estomac du patient ce mini estomac
gros comme à pot de yaourt va être relié
directement à l'intestin grêle
résultat le patient fera de plus petit
repas et surtout son diabète rapidement
s'améliorer et bien avant qu'il perde du
poids
quelques semaines quelques mois après
l'intervention on a déjà un effet majeur
sur les taux de glucose plutôt de sucre
dans le sang
lle a probablement des mécanismes
insoupçonnées jusque là qui sont liées à
des hormones qui sont modifiés en
modifiant d'anatomie le tube digestif et
ce sont ces hormones libéré par
l'intestin qui vont influer sur le
cerveau et sur le foie pour permettre à
l'organisme de mieux gérer son
utilisation du sucre daniel héron est un
bel exemple dans la réussite de ce
traitement ce sexagénaire picard est
passé de 185 à 135 kg en plusieurs mois
mais au bout de quelques semaines son
traitement du diabète n'était plus qu'un
souvenir
j'ai perdu environ 25 kg maëlys émis
sont de 112 5 en même temps vous avez pu
traitement bac 3
les spécialistes espèrent maintenant
mettre au point des médicaments qui
reproduiront les mêmes effets que la
chirurgie de façon un peu paradoxal donc
à terme cette technique de pointe est
appelée à disparaître
voilà nous revenons en cette fin de
journal sur la principale actualité de
cette journée ce mini-remaniement et je
vous propose d'écouter le premier
commentaire de
l'un des entrants dans cette équipe il
s'agit de georges tron secrétaire d'état
à la fonction publique
c'est un proche de dominique de villepin
alors faut-il parler de réconciliation
entre l'ancien premier ministre et
nicolas sarkozy écoute et georges tron
ce soir la politique c'est parfois alors
de mettre le bon sens en avant oui c'est
un geste d'apaisement que je prends
comme ça ma modeste personne parfois que
je vous répète que soit le bonheur du
moment il faut se remettre à sa juste
place ma modeste personne n'est rien
d'autre que la qu'un geste qui est fait
à l'égard de des villepinistes donc par
définition
prenons le pour ce qu'il est pour un
souci de se rassembler le rassemblement
autour du président je répète doit se
faire parce que c'est l'intérêt de la
majorité c'est exactement ce qu'on dit
de me les électeurs hier voilà pour ce
premier commentaire avant de refermer ce
journal je vous en rappelle donc à l'un
des principaux titres on l'évoqué à
l'instant après les régionales l'elysée
annonce un remaniement gouvernemental
très limité c'était il ya une heure le
chiraquien françois baroin fait son
entrée ainsi que georges tron viens de
l'entendre et le centriste marc philippe
daubresse xavier darcos est écarté
nicolas sarkozy a donc voulu intégrer
toutes les composantes de sa majorité
enfin de cette édition merci à vous tous
ou tu te la météo laurent romejko nous
conseille de profiter de la journée de
demain car ça va se gâter
20h35 fbi portés disparus n'oubliez pas
à 22h05 mots croisés avec yves calvi la
nouvelle donne après les régionales à
demain
toute l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france.fr